no
[Música]
ah
i
no dejes para mañana lo que puedas leer
hoy el promedio de lectura en colombia
es de 29 libros por año lo cual para mí
es una cifra muy baja en países como la
india o china el promedio de lectura es
de 11 horas en la semana esto significa
que una persona puede leer fácilmente de
4 a 8 libros en el mes ellos nos
demuestran que siempre hay tiempo para
un buen libro ellos usen momentos de
ocio para leer y usualmente cargan un
libro en sus maletas que cargamos en
nuestras maletas alguien trae consigo un
libro
por otra parte las estadísticas dicen
que a los niños de 0 a 5 años les
encanta que les lean esto es fenomenal
ya que si a esta edad les empezamos a
leer crearemos un hábito en ellos y se
enamoraran de la lectura tal como yo
pero quiero decirles que yo no solo leo
libros como muchos piensan
yo soy niño normal que me gusta jugar
fútbol jugar ajedrez ir al cine
compartir con mi familia jugar en la
consola mi vida es normal yo aprovecho
el tiempo y pienso que siempre hay
tiempo para un buen libro el mundo está
cambiando en la forma de cómo vemos y
hacemos las cosas por eso creo que en
unos años la lectura será algo normal y
dejará de sorprendernos que un niño lea
tanto esos niveles de baja lectura que
se manejan en colombia incluso en
américa latina deben cambiar y nosotros
estamos llamados a hacer la diferencia y
cambiarlos desde nosotros mismos desde
nuestras nuevas generaciones
mi hábito por la lectura se puede decir
que empezó desde la barriga de mi mamá
y mis padres me han contado que me leían
todas las noches los cuentos de rafael
pombo y adicional escuchaban las
canciones de estos cuentos cuando nací
me leían historias de la biblia para
bebés todas las noches antes de ir a
dormir y así se fue formando mi hábito y
mi amor por los libros no podía ir a
dormir sin que me contarán una historia
y me acostumbraron a siempre cargar un
libro en mi maleta yo aprendí a leer a
los cinco años leyendo cuentos e
historias cortas a los seis años llegó a
mis manos el principito que seguro
muchos de ustedes lo conocen y saben que
es increíble y tiene muchas enseñanzas
como por ejemplo que lo esencial es
invisible para los ojos este libro era
tan emocionante que no podía dejar de
leerlo así que lo leí en pocos días y
desde ese momento empecé a enamorarme de
los libros
me gustan mucho las sagas porque son
historias largas y puedo vivir muchas
aventuras con los personajes igualmente
he aprendido a disfrutar cada libro que
llega a mis manos
un día en el 2017 note que a mis amigos
del colegio no les gustaba leer como a
mí por lo que tuve la idea de crear un
club de lectura para que otras personas
se apasionaron por los libros y
sintieran amor por la lectura al llegar
del colegio les conté a mis padres la
idea ellos se miraron y aceptaron
apoyarme lo primero que hicimos fue
pensar en un nombre en ese momento
estaba entrenando karate y la cultura
japonesa me llamaba mucho la atención
así que después de buscar un poco me
gusta la palabra tocuyo que significa
lectura en japonés lo segundo fue crear
una imagen con ayuda de un amigo le
corté las cosas que me gustaban y él
empezó a dibujar en el computador
finalmente entre los dos creamos el logo
que uso en todas mis redes sociales el
logo está conformado por mis colores
favoritos el azul y el rojo y tiene
forma del libro los ojos de búho
simbolizan la sabiduría y las espadas
samurai porque somos los guerreros de la
lectura
[Aplausos]
cuando tuvimos cuando tuvimos esto mis
papás crearon una cuenta en instagram
empezamos a grabar vídeos con el celular
ya compartirlos con los amigos esto se
hacía de vez en cuando hasta que los
amigos empezaron a pedir que subiera
vídeos con más frecuencia y por eso
grabó un vídeo semanalmente donde hablo
de algunos de los libros que me he leído
en el año en el 2017 contamos y fueron
en total 83 libros leídos después de
esto no ha vuelto a contar pero el
promedio es 8 libros por mes
no me interesa tanto la cantidad sino la
calidad de la lectura
esto ha sido una gran experiencia porque
me ha permitido llegar a muchas personas
y mostrarles con mi ejemplo lo lindo de
la lectura y transmitirlo en la misma
emoción que me generan a mí los libros
si me preguntaran porque creo que las
personas no leen o no tienen un hábito
para la lectura les diría que las
para la lectura por dos simples razones
primero los padres los padres son la
influencia más importante en los hijos
si un padre no lee porque el lenguaje de
leer así que padres la primera
estrategia para que sus hijos se
conviertan en grandes lectores es
servirles de ejemplo si nosotros vemos a
nuestros padres leyendo no hay duda de
que nos darán ganas de leer
y segundo el sistema educativo muchos
padres le dejan toda la responsabilidad
al sistema para que los niños aprendan
lo que podamos aprender nos enseñan de
todo a leer a escribir la estructura un
párrafo repetir memorizar un nuevo
idioma todo pero una de las cosas más
importantes que no nos enseñan es el
hábito de la lectura a enamorarnos de la
lectura
[Aplausos]
y ahora pensemos qué pasaría si en
nuestras ciudades aumentamos el nivel de
lectura
los científicos han demostrado que las
personas que leen tienen mejor
desarrollo del cerebro porque lo
ejercita también alimenta la imaginación
mejora la comunicación y el liderazgo y
desarrolla la visión y todo esto hace
que los países lectores sobresalgan en
muchas actividades por encima de países
donde el nivel de lectura es bajo
ahora te voy a decir dos razones por las
cuales a mí me gusta leer primero
aprendes mucho más leer te puede enseñar
muchas cosas como por ejemplo nuevas
palabras o escribir las que ya conocidas
y segundo imaginación la imaginación es
algo fundamental para el cerebro con la
imaginación puedes viajar veinte mil
leguas en un submarino con el capitán
nemo puedes perderte en una isla que ya
está perdida puedes resolver misteriosos
casos con el gran dios ismo sherlock
holmes o mejor aún puedes ganarte el
premio nobel de la literatura como lo
hizo cabe el garcía márquez que toda su
vida leyó hoy de yo hasta convertirse en
lo que fue
para mí esta aventura ha traído muchas
recompensas que no esperaba cuando todo
inició no sólo el reconocimiento en
medios de comunicación sino también
ganar un concurso internacional de book
to bears y ser invitado a otro país
después de todo esto quiero preguntarte
que te están leyendo y a quién le estás
dando ejemplo
por eso quiero proponerte el reto de
leer 20 minutos al día e influir a que
otras personas también lo hagan
finalmente quiero dejarlos con una frase
de un autor desconocido que me gusta
mucho
un niño que lee será un adulto que
piensa y tú te unes a la aventura
[Aplausos]